gunfire and explosions in India's
Northeastern State of Manipur
this is the latest in weeks of violence
between the cookie tribal group and the
ethnic majority may take people
India's home minister arrived in Manipur
on Monday he is the most senior official
from New Delhi to visit since the unrest
began
violent activities of the arms to be
carriers and others have a lot to do
with the visit of the Indian home
minister Mr Amit Shah to inform and
probably to other districts of Manipur
as well particularly sultanpur Technical
and kankoppi District
dozens of people have been killed and at
least 35
000 forced from their homes since the
unrest began nearly four weeks ago
tribal groups were angered After
manipur's High Court recommended
granting tribal status to the Mayte who
make up half of the state's population
that would allow them to own land in
tribal dominated areas cookie protesters
in New Delhi are now calling for more
intervention from the central government
we are clueless as to what's going to
happen what about our safety because of
all this tension I felt ill as well I
could couldn't step out of my home and
couldn't go to work for two to three
days we are frustrated and scared
thinking about the future
the Indian army has launched a Security
operation and sent reinforcements to
Manipur people caught in the unrest here
can only hope that will curb the
violence
Felix Noir Al Jazeera